[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA SLABIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Laura Slabin, and
I'm very excited to have
with us today Gillian
Anderson and Jennifer Nadel,
who wrote the book, "We--
a Manifesto for
Women Everywhere."
I will start with their bios
and a little bit about the book,
and then we'll go
into some questions.
So Gillian Anderson is an
award-winning film, television
and theater actor and
producer, writer, and activist.
She currently lives in London
with her daughter and two sons.
And Jennifer Nadel is an
award-winning broadcast
journalist, qualified
attorney, writer, and activist.
American-born, she lives in
London with her three sons.
So "We," the way
they've described it,
"is a movement for
change, a manifesto
for female-led revolution,
a quiet, peaceful about face
that doesn't require the
consent of those in power.
It just asks each one of
us, one woman at a time,
to be the change and take
the journey from me to we."
And when I read that, when
I was reading the book,
I thought it was
extremely timely
given what is going
on in the world
today with different
leadership here in America,
with Brexit in London.
So I want to thank you
both for being here.
I know it's been a very hectic
week with your schedules.
Before I delve into
the book, I wanted
to discuss two
ideas that I think
that this Google audience would
find of particular interest.
And that women in tech
as well as pay equality.
So how many people
here in the room
were fans of Scully
and "The X-Files"?
I have to raise my hand as well.
And how many of you are
familiar with the Scully Effect?
A few?
Just a few.
So for those that have not
heard of the Scully Effect,
it's believed that
Gillian's character, Scully,
who was a medical doctor,
an FBI specialist,
inspired many young women to
pursue careers in science,
medicine, and law enforcement,
bringing an actual perceptible
increase in the number
of women in those fields.
So that's pretty
interesting, and I
know we talk a lot
here at Google of how
do we get more women in tech?
Who are the role
models, et cetera?
And how do we get more
diversity and inclusively?
So I think Hollywood, as well,
seems to be having a shakeup
right now.
And I'm wondering what are some
of the factors that are helping
to bring about that
change and what
do you think can be done
to further stimulate change
in Hollywood or
in women in tech?
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Well,
it seems like things
are being stimulated
in Hollywood, you know,
when someone like
Patricia Arquette
makes a statement at the
Oscars and Meryl Streep
has been very, very vocal about
pay equality in that industry.
And overall, having women
very publicly speak out
about the fact of it, and you
all may know of the letter
that Jennifer Lawrence wrote,
which was beautifully worded--
those things, I think,
on the one hand,
it keeps the conversation
alive, and also it
emboldens women to
have that conversation.
It empowers them to be able
to have that conversation
for themselves.
It's a complicated
issue, you know.
And I don't know what
the percentage is
of female employees at Google.
But I know in my
industry, it feels
like something one actually has
very, very little control over.
Because at the end
of the day, it's
up to the writers, the casting
directors, the producers.
And as we all know, so often
the roles of females to men
not only are minimal, but they
end up being women in their 20s
when their love interests
or their husbands
are in their 50s, et
cetera, et cetera.
But it is an ongoing
and increasingly talked
about conversation
that I think that there
are some changes in the
process that are being made.
JENNIFER NADEL: And
I think all of us
can have an influence as well,
because ultimately Hollywood
is giving us what
Hollywood thinks we want.
So if we start
changing what we want,
which is part of what this book
is about-- this book is about
really getting to recognize
what is intrinsic to us, what
our authentic wants
and tastes are,
and those that have been imposed
and that we've just absorbed
without even realizing
that we have internalized,
you know, the male gaze.
We have internalized a
very typically male way
of looking at women.
And as we start to shed that,
Hollywood needs to make money
and wants to make
money, so it's up to us
where we decide to put
our bottoms on seats.
LAURA SLABIN: Makes sense.
So I want to delve
into the book.
And it's a very
personal, and I would
say, deeply personal book.
And I'm going to share
a quote with everyone.
It says, "Let us out of darkness
from a place where both of us
were suicidal and in despair
and into a way of life that
has meaning and purpose."
So sharing that,
I'm just curious
why you decided
to write the book
and share such personal
stories throughout.
And I'm curious also if you
were reticent about sharing
those vulnerabilities.
JENNIFER NADEL: Good questions.
I mean, we're quite
extreme cases.
We like to take
things to extremes.
And you know, I
think both of us have
been seekers since our teens.
We've been up against the
edge of things since then.
And so as a result, we
have really been obliged.
The reason we're still here
and able to sit in front of you
reasonably, sometimes
articulately-- not always--
is because of the stuff that
we have distilled down and put
in this book.
That's why we're alive today,
because we were obliged
to really, really seek answers.
And the reason we wanted
to put those answers down
was, I think, that
it's a gift in a way,
if you've had no option
but to look for answers.
But many people live with
a level of misery and pain,
many women, in particular.
It just isn't
necessary to live with.
And if we look at
rates of self-harm--
Gillian's got a
good figure on that.
And addiction and eating
disorders and depression
amongst women in particular,
you know, we have an epidemic.
So something is not working,
despite this amazing society
that we've created
for ourselves.
Something is going badly wrong.
So that was one of the things
that we wanted to address.
GILLIAN ANDERSON:
And also, the book
is based on nine principles,
which are essentially
tools or universal values
like honesty and humility
and courage and trust.
But one of the
foundation principles,
actually, the first
one is honesty,
which goes throughout all
of the other principles.
Because unless we
can really, really
get honest about what's going
on for us, where our sorrow is,
what the truth of our lives
and what works for us is,
then it's very difficult
to then step out
of that and into
another solution.
And so in asking readers to be
that honest in their process,
it became very
important that we too
were willing to get honest
about some of the stuff that's
gone on for us.
And it's been interesting
the last week,
because I speak in the
book about a couple things
that I've gone honest about.
One is periods of
time where I've
suffered from
massive panic attacks
and also with my
struggles with parenting
and how hard I sometimes
find parenting.
And in this last week,
a lot of the headlines
has been, celebrities
with mental health issues.
Part of what we're trying
to do with this book
is to talk about them and
the solution, the solution
to those things
that bring up panic
and anxiety and
uncertainty and fear
and the desire to eat
six tubs of Haagen-Dazs
or spends 15 hours of
gaming every afternoon
or whatever it is
that is our escape.
Part of what we talk
about in the book
are ways that we can start to
wean ourselves off those things
and do things that bring much
more meaning in our lives.
And so it's interesting how
in being honest about some
of the things that I
have gone through it
then becomes a negative.
There's the negative
twist on it,
which is part of what--
we're used to being bombarded
by so much negativity
when actually it's
a means to an end, ultimately,
if you look at it that way.
LAURA SLABIN: Will
you share a little bit
about how you came up
with the nine principles?
I'm sure at some point there
were maybe more than nine.
[LAUGHTER]
Then how you wittled them down?
JENNIFER NADEL: That's
such a good question.
That's such a good question.
What we found, we
kind of put everything
that we wanted to say--
the book really takes
the reader on a journey.
And it starts off,
as Gillian said,
with honesty and with our
relationship with ourselves.
And then it finishes
with kindness,
which is about how we engage
with the world at large
and how we go about helping
to be a part of bringing
the changes that need to be
brought so that our society is
more compassionate and
fairer and more equal.
So we put everything
down, and we just thought,
what are the essentials in here?
And often they
were similar words.
We had a long debate about
kindness or compassion.
What should the
ninth principle be?
So sometimes it was
kind of something
that was close, but not quite.
So we had to pick and choose.
But in terms of the nine, they
kind of revealed themselves,
I think.
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Also one
of the things we wanted to do
was to use the positive
side of the principle
that we're talking about.
So courage, for
instance, is actually
really about anger and
resentment and the things
that we're holding onto that we
can't quite seem to let go of,
and really digging
honestly into those things,
and being courageous
enough to look
at the things which actually eat
away at us on a daily basis--
those little hurts that
maybe we haven't let go of,
or the person that we haven't
talked to in a few years,
those areas where we end up
getting very tightly closed
and not wanting to deal with,
having the courage, to then,
to face them, and to
get honest with what
our own part in that dynamic is.
And so courage is actually
a lot about resentment,
and it's the principles are
the positive side of maybe
trickier things to deal with.
LAURA SLABIN: And one of the
things that you recommended
in your book, in addition to
following the nine principles,
was meditation.
And I personally
continue to hear
how wonderful meditation is.
I have attempted many times.
I have apps on my
phone that are supposed
to help with meditation.
I do yoga, and I still
have not personally
gotten something to stick.
And if you'll just
share a little bit
about what your
personal meditation
practices are and any advice for
us on how can we find our own?
I think that those of us at
Google, we're traveling a lot.
We're busy.
There's a lot going
on in our minds.
So I think finding that
practice would be very helpful.
JENNIFER NADEL: I think it's so
important because so many of us
are so identified
with our thoughts
that we don't realize that
that's not who we are.
Our thoughts are
just our thoughts,
and our true self
resides in a silent place
underneath our thoughts.
But I found
meditation impossible
for a long period
of time, because I
would go-- even that little bit
at the end of the yoga class,
where you're just meant to lie
still, that would be torture.
Because I would feel
like I was lying
with a swarm of angry wasps
that were just going to come
and sting me if I lay still,
which was my thinking,
you know, those attack
thoughts that we all have.
And then a friend suggested
just try two minutes.
And I was like, what's
the point of two minutes?
I'm an extreme person.
I like extreme, big answers.
And it worked.
Because anyone can
find two minutes.
And you can set
it on your phone,
and it doesn't matter
how much pain it has.
But what that two minutes
did was it started a habit.
A meditation is a habit.
And once you start--
really small, don't stretch
beyond where you can.
And we describe in
the book-- we start
with suggesting that practice.
But a lot of the time, we have
to kind of scrape away and heal
a lot of our wounds.
Because otherwise, it is
torture to sit with ourselves.
So it's further on
in the book that we
talk about how to
deepen that practice
and stretch it out to--
you know, I try and
do 20 every day.
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Yeah, me too.
But I started meditating when I
was in high school, initially,
but also extended it
into periods of time
when I was drunk.
Now it's a very different
practice that I have.
But one of the things that
used to drive me insane
was if I didn't have the
candle, if I wasn't facing
the right way, if I didn't have
the right cushion, if I didn't,
then it didn't feel like
it was perfect in some way,
or that the experience
of the meditation
was as deep as it
could have been.
And then I was away
filming something,
and the only viable
place to meditate
was on the kitchen floor
next to the refrigerator.
And I had one of the most
extraordinary meditation
experiences of my life,
and it was purely a gift
to show me that I could
kind of do it anywhere.
I can do it anywhere.
I can do it on set.
I can do it in hotel rooms.
I can do it.
I don't need to have all those
perfect environmental things
to have it work for me.
JENNIFER NADEL: And
also, you know, you
talked about having
it on your phone.
It's kind of been
co-opted meditation,
and it's become another
thing that we have to do.
Have I done my meditation yet?
Have I done my exercise?
And actually, it's
not about doing.
It's about being.
And if one's doing it
to get an end result,
then you're kind of
shortchanging yourself.
And if you can just trust--
so often we need to know
what's going to happen.
But if you can just
trust that process,
and trust that those
millions of people who've
done it through the
centuries know something,
then it will start to work.
LAURA SLABIN: I'll
find two minutes
before going to
bed this evening.
I mentioned that I thought
it was an interesting time
in the history right now.
And women, I think,
are mobilizing
more and more with marches,
with strikes, et cetera.
And from reading the book
and a little bit more
about both of your
backgrounds, it's clear
that you are both feminists,
and I think strong role models
for many women out there.
And I'm wondering
what your hopes
are for the women's
movement, and in writing
this manifesto, and et cetera.
JENNIFER NADEL: Well,
it's interesting.
You talked about the timing,
because two years ago,
when we started
writing it, Gillian
had this very
strong sense that it
should be called a manifesto.
And everyone was like, women
don't want a manifesto.
It's too political.
It's too dogmatic.
No one cares.
And Gillian just had--
I think because, well, for many
reasons, but that meditation.
You know, when you
meditate regularly, you--
anyway, you intuit.
She's got a very
strong intuition.
That's what I'm trying to
say about my writing buddy.
But it turns out,
two years on, no one
is saying we don't
need a manifesto.
Unfortunately, no
one is saying, why
have you written a
manifesto for women?
Unfortunately,
it's all too clear
that we do need something.
And our hope is-- we're all
going to need to be resilient.
Activism is no longer a choice.
It's now an essential.
All of us who have the
capacity and the voice
need to show up, particularly
for those who are
too scared and most at risk.
And if we're going to do that,
we need to develop resilience,
because just as you
can burn out from work,
you can burn up from activism.
And there's no point
in going into it
if you're driven by your
ego, because often there
are no quick results.
And often it is just about
showing up and saying, I care.
I believe.
I'm here.
I'm not going away.
Sorry, this is very--
GILLIAN ANDERSON: No, go ahead.
JENNIFER NADEL: Anyway, so this
book is really a blueprint.
It's a handbook
and it's a manual.
And one of the things that
we really hope will happen,
has already started to
happen-- and it only came out
a week ago-- already, it's
very inspiring hearing back
that it is happening,
is that women
will gather together with
other women and start circles.
You know, the image on
the front of the book,
if we have an image of
the book-- yes, there.
There.
It is a circle.
So gathering together with
one or more other women
and having the conversations
that are in the book,
doing the work that
is in the book,
and then you'll
see there's a link.
You know, the circles, there
are three circles linked
on the cover.
And then linking up
with other women,
and growing and
growing and growing.
So I hope that it
will be very relevant.
And we hope that women
will find other women
whether in the workplace,
online, school gates,
going into whatever
age-- schools,
old people's homes-- and
just starting conversations,
forming connections.
Because whenever two or more
women are gathered together,
amazing things can happen.
LAURA SLABIN: Do you have
any role models today
that you look at as we
think about how to mobilize
or who you're having
these circles with?
GILLIAN ANDERSON: One of
the most amazing young women
out there today is
Malala Yousafzai
and how incredibly
courageous and articulate
she is, standing up for
education in schools
at the cost of quite a lot and
in the face of quite a lot,
in a way that we certainly don't
yet anyway have that experience
in are apparently
free countries.
LAURA SLABIN: And as
we think about impact,
I think a lot of us at Google
think about impact at scale,
because our company is all
about reaching people at scale.
And I'm curious if you have
any suggestions for those
of us here who do want to have a
larger impact of what you think
we can be doing at scale
to make a difference.
JENNIFER NADEL: Telling it
as it is, not shying away
from the truth, and providing
a platform for other people
to organize and to connect.
That's one of the
things that we've
been looking for is a way of--
women joining together
face-to-face is essential.
But how can we all join up.
So many of us wake up at
3 o'clock in the morning,
and that's the moment
when we actually want
to connect with someone else.
And that's the moment when it's
not appropriate most the time
to connect with someone else.
So you can come up with a way.
LAURA SLABIN: I'm
often up at 3:00 AM.
JENNIFER NADEL: All of us--
GILLIAN ANDERSON: I've got
two answers to this question.
My first response was,
kindness is contagious.
And we really, really
need more kindness
in the world today than
ever before, I think.
And it is contagious,
and that can scale up.
But also, we are interested in
creating a community of women
online as well as in person.
And so much of that has to do
with funding and sponsorship
and ideas, ideas from people who
know how to make that happen,
to create a safe place
for women to communicate
and to communicate about
things that are not
just important to them and
their experience with this book,
but also communicate in an
altruistic way about how they
are going out into
the world and showing
that the change that they're
working on the inside
is having impact on the outside.
And we say women specifically
for the community,
because there's
a lot of violence
against women out there.
And there's a lot of
women who experience
that on a daily basis.
And creating a
safe place for them
to be able to talk
openly and feel
like they're not
getting further abuse
is a really important thing.
LAURA SLABIN: Trolls online,
it's definitely an issue.
So the manifesto is obviously
a manifesto for women,
but I'm curious, do you think
your principles apply equally
to men?
And why is it not a
manifesto for all?
JENNIFER NADEL:
Yeah, absolutely.
All the men we know
who've read the book
love it and say what about me?
And the truth is that any
man can read this book
and get a lot from it.
And if you take the
cover off, there's
a really anonymous thing.
So if you're embarrassed about
reading a manifesto for women,
you guys, just
take the cover off.
But yeah, the principles
are universal.
They apply to everyone.
But for the reasons
that Gillian said,
we need to start with women.
Women do 75% of the
work across the globe,
earn 10% of the wages, and
own 1% of the property.
We need to start
with us and also
because a lot of the time
as feminists we're fighting
for access to 50% of a
system that doesn't work,
a system that has left us with
facing runaway climate change,
hate crimes on the rise,
depression on the rise,
self-harm on the rise,
inequality growing, things
that we know are not OK.
And yet, our system
doesn't fix them.
It exacerbates them.
So part of our hope
for the book as well
is that it's not
just about trying
to get 50% of a broken system.
It's about a paradigm shift.
It's about co-creating a
world that works for women
and for men, because I think men
are as trapped by our existing
structures.
Because they're
really about power.
They're really about units
of labor that traditionally
have been male, and
so no one needed
to take account of the fact that
they may have responsibilities
beyond the workplace.
But most men today do, and
most men today want to.
So it's about
together saying, as we
were saying about
Hollywood, we've
got to say it in every area.
This is not what we want.
It doesn't work.
Actually, we want equality.
Actually, we want fairness.
Actually, we will take
home less in our pay packet
so that we can take care
of those who are sick,
or who aren't able to earn
in the way that we are.
It's about co-creating
a fairer world.
LAURA SLABIN: One
thing you discussed
was a gratitude practice.
I find that much
easier than meditation.
And I just thought
it'd be fun if you
would share with us what was
in your gratitude practice
yesterday.
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Well,
yesterday was a snow day.
So I had a lot of
gratitude yesterday.
I had gratitude for pajamas,
and snow, and a hotel room,
which sometimes is really nice.
And I mean, most of the
time my gratitude has
to do with the simplest things.
One of the statistics
in the book,
I believe if I've
got this right,
is that if you have
a refrigerator,
you are richer than
75% of the population.
So I'm grateful
for a lot, a lot.
LAURA SLABIN: Jennifer?
JENNIFER NADEL: Yeah, I had the
snow, because I love the snow.
I've got my son
with me, so that's
a huge source of gratitude.
I found cabs, even though I was
told there would be no cabs.
I found them, and the
drivers were all lovely.
And for me, those
moments of kindness,
those moments of
human connection,
often just little things like
buying a newspaper from someone
and forming a human contact,
not just throwing the money
and taking the goods,
but actually connecting.
You know, love is all
around if we're open to it.
LAURA SLABIN: We have time--
this will be the last question.
What's next for you
after writing this book?
JENNIFER NADEL: Aside from
trying to start a movement,
I'm going to go and
write my second novel,
maybe even finish my PhD.
Oh, and I'm making a film for
the Green Party in the UK.
GILLIAN ANDERSON:
Immediately next
is actually a big
lump of nothing,
which I have been asking
for for a really long time.
And a series of what,
on the one hand,
might be unfortunate
events, have actually
turned into fortunate
nothingness.
And because I've been pretty
much either on a plane,
on a set, or with my kids
for years, years, and hearing
myself say, I've
got to slow down.
I've got to slow down.
I've got to-- I've got
to, you know, and I've
been given this space and
time to clean out my closet,
clean out my purse,
explore my neighborhoods.
One of the biggest things is
actually I do a lot of work
speaking up about
human trafficking
and modern-day slavery.
And one of the things that
drives me a little bit crazy
is that the busyness
of my schedule
means that I can't
necessarily be on the ground
or be as physically
involved as I'd like to be.
So that's partly what I'd like
to do is to get physically more
involved.
LAURA SLABIN: That sounds
like an aggressive and busy
nothingness.
[LAUGHTER]
Is there anything--
GILLIAN ANDERSON:
Every once in a while.
JENNIFER NADEL: Good spot.
LAURA SLABIN: Any part
of the nothingness,
like sitting on a beach
or hiking or meditating?
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Sure.
I'm sure there will be.
I might have to be
taught how to do that.
LAURA SLABIN: So I just
want to thank both of you
for being here with
your busy schedule,
and I hope that we
do start a movement.
So thank you very much.
GILLIAN ANDERSON: Thank
you for having us.
[APPLAUSE]
as